Let's take another look at the original ellipse we first encountered at the
start of the lesson. We knew that this ellipse was centered at the origin 0, 0,
in that we moved two units left and right to get a point and three units up and
down from the center to get two more points. But, not every ellipse is going to
be centered at the origin. Sometimes they can be elsewhere. Just like we could
shift circles, we could also shift ellipses. So, if I wanted to graph this one,
I would notice that the graph would shift up one whole unit. Remember, when we
replace y with y minus a number, the graph really shifts up that many units.
And instead of just shifting up one unit, I could also shift it up two units.
We could shift it up three units, four units or even five units. The key thing
to remember is that this sign is the opposite of the direction the ellipse
moves. So now let's say if we are looking at our original lips and we want to
move it down instead of subtracting from y we'll add to y. So if we add 1 to y,
we'll get a shift downward. Our entire orange ellipse moved down one unit. And
we get this new blue ellipse. And I could continue shifting it further down by
adding a larger number, like two, or three, or four and so on. So we know
adding or subtracting the y makes a graph, or an ellipse move up or down. So to
move a graph left or right, we'll have to add or subtract to x. So again,
notice that I have my original graph, and this time I'm going to subtract 1
from x. If I subtract one from x, I'll get this graph. Notice that all the
points on our ellipse shifted one unit to the right. Here's just a few of the
points that you can see that all shifted one unit to the right. And if we
wanted to, we could shift two units to the right, three units to the right, or
even four. And again, notice that this is a subtraction sign. So if it's a
negative here, we're really moving to the right. But if it's a positive here,
we're really moving to the left. So this new equation would be our original
orange ellipse, just shifted one unit to the left. And notice that we have plus
1. A plus 1 really shifted it to the left. So plus 2 would shift it 2 units to
the left. And plus 3 would shift it 3 units to the left.